mes efforts de l'armée ukrainienne sont
ils en train de s'avérer payant après
six mois de conflit après avoir
revendiqué tout au long du week-end de
nouveaux succès militaires volodymyr
zelensky s'est targué hier soir de
reprendre du terrain sur les russes
d'avoir repris trois mille kilomètres
carrés à l'est et nouveautés en ce début
d'après midi le porte parole de l'armée
ukrainienne applaudi des progrès
également sur le front sud on va
retrouver tout de suite en direct de qui
est notre correspondant gulliver craag
bonjour gulliver l'ukraine dit
effectivement avoir repris cette fois
500 kilomètres carrés au russe dans le
sud du pays
oui depuis quelques jours nathalie rue
migneault que la porte parole pour les
forces armées ukrainiennes dans le sud
du pays dit qu'il y a des progrès et
qu'il va y avoir des bonnes nouvelles à
annoncer bientôt mais aujourd'hui c'est
la première fois qu'elle y met un
chiffre en terme de kilomètres carrés
repris ce serait sain sont alors mais ce
sont des informations très difficile à
vérifier contrairement à ce qui se passe
dans l'est du pays dans la région de
rare qu'yves il y a très peu de photos
et de vidéos qui sortent pour le moment
du sud de la région de personnes et on
pense que l'armée ukrainienne a plus de
difficultés dans cette région a avancé
qu'elle n'a retrouvé dans la région de
rare qu'yves mais ce qui est vrai c'est
que pendant l'été l'armée ukrainienne a
effectué un nombre de frappes très
importantes sur les ponts et autres
éléments de la logistique russe dans le
sud du pays ce qui fait que du moins la
rive droite du dnipro dans la région de
personnes c'est une région qui est
découpée par le fleuve dnipro et est
très difficile d'accès pour les russes
pour les approvisionnements parce que
ils ont vraiment beaucoup de difficultés
à traverser le fleuve donc la
préparation en tout cas de ce contre
offensive ukrainienne dont le sud était
très bon et s'est déroulé pendant très
longtemps et aussi ce que on peut penser
et c'est ce qui en sortent de ce qu'on
voit à la télévision russe par exemple
c'est que le moral des russes a subi un
coup très grave du fait de ces avancées
très rapide dont la région des rares
kiffe ce qui peut avoir eu peut-être un
effet aussi sur la performance si vous
voulez de leur ville terre dans le sud
et l'est russie ont réagi à ce matin par
la voix de leur porte parole porte
parole du kremlin moscou qui confirme
effectivement hier s'être retirée de
plusieurs positions stratégiques répond
aujourd'hui que l'offensive va continuer
jusqu'à ce que les objectifs soient
atteints les ruses qui annonce que les
localités reprises par les ukrainiens
sont intensément bombardé cet après-midi
avez vous des informations à ce niveau
là
les informations que j'ai c'est plutôt
des informations sur la réponse des rues
ça c'est à bosser des ukrainiens dont la
région de harkis à part le fait
d'essayer de qualifier leur retrait d'un
redéploiement
ils ont aussi une réplique violente dans
le sens oui bombardent la capitale
régionale la ville d'art qui il ya eu
une explosion très forte dans le centre
ville il y à une quarantaine de minutes
il y a aussi eu quelques explosions à
moins forte et bien sûr il ya eu ces
attaques hier soir qui ont coupé le
courant l'électricité dans la ville
d'arrivée à d'autres endroits dans cette
région et dans trois autres régions
aussi de l'est de l'ukraine ce qui fait
que parmi nos favoris et la fierté qui
gagne le pays en ce moment il y a aussi
un sentiment un peu de peur de quels
seront les représailles et à la
vengeance que les russes vont devoir
vous mourrez c'est maintenant d'avoir
sur les ukrainiens merci beaucoup lui
l'hiver en direct de kia vient en rien